This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. And I'm here with reporter Daniel Ackerman. Hey, Dan. Hi, Roman. So you reached out to us because you wanted to tell us about a very specific tool that you say completely revolutionized American consumer culture and created the blueprint for the modern retail economy. It's like big words, if true. Yeah. So when you think about how many of us shop today, it's something that you can do whenever and wherever you want.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马斯。今天和我一起的是记者丹尼尔·阿克曼。嘿，丹。嗨，罗曼。所以你找到我们，是想给我们讲一个非常特殊的工具，你认为这个工具彻底革新了美国的消费文化，并为现代零售经济绘制了蓝图。如果属实的话，这口气可真不小。是的。所以，当你想到我们现在有多少人购物时，你会发现这是一种你可以在任何时间、任何地点随心所欲去做的事情。
Like you could be in bed at 3 a.m. hit a couple buttons on your phone, and the next morning, there's a vacuum cleaner sitting on your doorstep. And that shopping impulse is not bound by time or distance, right? Right. Well, you can trace this 24-7 shopping mentality back to the 1960s, when AT&T introduced a revolutionary technology for commerce. And this is something that almost everyone listening has used at some point in their lives. And if you haven't figured it out yet, Roman, I'm talking about the inward-wide area telephone service. or inwats for sure.
比如你可以凌晨三点躺在床上，在手机上按几个按钮，第二天早上，门口就放着一台吸尘器。这种购物冲动不受时间和距离的限制，对吧？没错。好吧，这种 7×24 小时的购物心态可以追溯到 20 世纪 60 年代，当时美国电话电报公司（AT&T）推出了一项革命性的商业技术。几乎所有在听节目的人都在生命中的某个时刻使用过这个东西。如果你还没猜出来的话，罗曼，我说的就是内向广域电话服务，简称 INWATS。
That wasn't what I had in mind, but okay, keep going. All right, all right. So just in case anyone listening isn't a complete telephony nerd, this technology is more commonly known as the 800 number. 800-588-8-800-58-8-8-6. Call one-800 Star Trek. Call one-800 general now! Oh, yes, of course.
这跟我心里想的完全不一样，不过好吧，你接着说。行，行。所以，以防收听节目的有人不是个彻头彻尾的电话极客，这项技术有个更广为人知的名字，叫 800 免费电话。800-588-8-800-58-8-8-6。拨打 1-800 星际迷航。立刻拨打 1-800 全能热线！哦，对，当然。
I've used many 800 numbers in my lifetime, but I don't know if I ever really consider it at technology, but of course it is. It's a really shockingly understudied part of the American economy, of American culture, of American society. Compared to something like advertising in general or television, the bookshelf on the history of telephony is pretty small. That is Rick Pop. He's a historian at the University of Wisconsin, Milwaukee. And he says that the 800 number was originally introduced by AT&T, not necessarily for shopping purposes, but because they were trying to, to solve another problem for businesses, which was that long-distance calling was really expensive for their customers.
我这辈子打过很多 800 电话，但我不知道自己是否真的把它当成过一项技术，但它当然是的。它是美国经济、美国文化、美国社会中一个极其被严重低估的部分。与一般意义上的广告或电视相比，关于电话发展史的书架可真是小得可怜。这位是里克·波普。他是密尔沃基威斯康星大学的历史学家。他说，AT&T 最初推出 800 电话，不一定是为了购物目的，而是因为他们试图为企业解决另一个问题，那就是长途电话对他们的客户来说真的非常昂贵。
Ordinary telephone users almost never made long-distance calls. I mean, they were so expensive. So if you were an average person, you might place a long-distance call every now and then to wish your grandma in St. Louis, happy birthday. But long-distance calling was basically a luxury at this time. Average consumers definitely did not want to have to pay a long-distance charge for something mundane like calling up a business to order a pair of jeans. If it was time-sensitive enough, then maybe you'd call and you'd eat the costs of the long-distance call, but for the most part, it was written communication. Now, if you're a large company or retailer fielding calls from consumers all over the country, it would make sense to take on those long-distance charges for your customers.
普通电话用户几乎从不打长途电话。我的意思是，它们太贵了。所以如果你是个普通人，你可能会偶尔打个长途电话，祝你在圣路易斯的奶奶生日快乐。但在当时，长途电话基本上是一种奢侈品。普通消费者绝对不想为了像打电话给企业订购一条牛仔裤这样平凡的事情，而去支付长途通话费。如果时间足够紧迫，那么也许你会打电话并自己承担长途电话费，但在大多数情况下，人们都会选择书面通信。现在，如果你是一家大型公司或零售商，需要处理来自全国各地消费者的来电，那么替客户承担这些长途费用将是合情合理的。
There was at least one way that customers could reach businesses toll-free, and that was by collect-calling. Roman, you remember collect-calling? Yes, I made a lot of collect calls. I had a lot of relatives in far-away places. In the early days, at least, you would actually dial zero, reach an operator, give them your name, and then they would make the call and ask if they would accept the charges on the other end. And if they said, yes, you got connected. And if they said, no, you just got disconnected. But in the beginning, you actually had to talk to an operator.
客户至少有一种方式可以免长途费联系企业，那就是对方付费电话。罗曼，你还记得对方付费电话吗？记得，我打过很多对方付费电话。我在远方有很多亲戚。至少在早期，你实际上得拨 0，接通接线员，报上你的名字，然后他们会拨打电话，询问对方是否愿意承担这笔费用。如果对方说愿意，你就接通了。如果对方说不愿意，通话就被挂断了。但在最初，你实际上必须和接线员对话。
Exactly. And for the younger crowd, I couldn't find an actual news clip showing how collect calling works. But here's a clip from Dr. Strangelove, which I think does the trick. No, I'm perfectly serious, operator. The president, yes, the president of the United States. Oh, I'm sorry, I haven't got enough change. Could you make this a collect call operator? Just one second, operator. They won't accept the call. Have you got 55 cents? Yeah, that's pretty much how it worked.
没错。对于年轻一代，我找不到展示对方付费电话如何运作的实际新闻片段。但这里有一段来自《奇爱博士》的片段，我觉得它能说明问题。不，我是认真的，接线员。总统，对，美国总统。哦，很抱歉，我零钱不够。你能把它转成对方付费电话吗，接线员？等一下，接线员。他们不接听这通电话。你有 55 美分吗？对，差不多就是这么运作的。
Right. And as that clip shows, in the 1960s, toll-free calling was a really inefficient process, right? Because you had to dial an operator, and then the charges needed to be accepted by the company. Or in the case of Dr. Strangelove, the president would have had to accept the charges. Exactly. And so AT&T, which was, you know, the largest phone company in the world at the time, they wanted to make this easier. They wanted to streamline this whole process. And that's one reason why they introduced in Watts, aka the 800 number, to automate that toll reversal. So, you know, no longer would a company have to go through this operator middleman.
没错。正如那个片段所显示的，在 20 世纪 60 年代，免长途费通话是一个效率极低的过程，对吧？因为你必须拨打接线员电话，然后费用需要由公司来承担。或者在《奇爱博士》的例子中，总统必须承担这笔费用。没错。因此，AT&T（当时世界上最大的电话公司）希望让这变得更容易。他们想要简化整个流程。这也是他们推出 INWATS（即 800 电话）以实现转付费自动化的原因之一。所以，公司再也不用通过接线员这个中间人了。
A business could just purchase an 800 number, which would automatically signal to AT&T, hey, don't charge our customers who are making the call, charge us, the business that's receiving the call instead. So this was first introduced in the 1960s, you said? And what did the early days of the 800 number look like? Well, it was pretty experimental. You know, companies were still just trying to figure out. out how to use this technology profitably.
企业只需购买一个 800 电话号码，这就会自动向 AT&T 发出信号：嘿，不要向打电话的客户收费，而是向我们——接听电话的企业收费。所以你刚说过，这是在 20 世纪 60 年代首次推出的？那 800 电话的早期是什么样的？嗯，相当具有实验性。你知道，公司当时仍在摸索如何盈利地使用这项技术。
And the initial results were kind of mixed. Rick Pop told me about one of the earliest companies to get an 800 number. It was this pretty established catalog retailer called Aldins. Now, they were a competitor of Sears, so they sold run-of-the-mill catalog stuff, like toys, clothes, kitchen appliances. But what Alden's tried to do was to take on this new 800-number technology and promote it as something like futuristic, where they could take customer orders at light speed. They came up with this idea shortly after N-WATS the 800 number is introduced
最初的结果可以说是喜忧参半。里克·波普跟我讲了一家最早获得 800 电话的公司。那是一家相当老牌的邮购零售商，叫奥尔登斯（Aldins）。当时，他们是西尔斯（Sears）的竞争对手，所以他们销售普通的邮购商品，比如玩具、衣服、厨房电器。但奥尔登斯试图做的是，采用这种崭新的 800 电话技术，并把它宣传得像未来科技一样，他们可以通过它以光速接受客户订单。他们在 800 电话推出后不久就想出了这个主意。
to run this really splashy 16-page advertisement in the Saturday Evening Post to basically promote the hell out of this 800 number that they had set up, which they called Jet Phone Service. Jet Phone Service. It's sleek. It's high-tech. A reminder that passenger jet travel was pretty new and glamorous at the time. And Aldens wanted to make the feeling of dialing an 800 number feel just like stepping on to a sleek new jet plane. So they set up 20 different 800 lines already to receive the onslaught of incoming orders through this new 800 system. But Rick Pop says they never actually came.
要在《星期六晚邮报》上刊登一个非常引人注目的 16 页广告，基本上就是大力宣传他们设立的这个 800 电话，他们将其称为“喷气电话服务”。喷气电话服务。它很时髦。它是高科技的。这提醒人们，客运喷气机旅行在当时是相当新颖和迷人的。奥尔登斯希望让拨打 800 电话的感觉，就像踏上一架时髦的新喷气式飞机一样。因此，他们设置了 20 条不同的 800 专线，准备迎接通过这个新的 800 系统涌入的订单狂潮。但里克·波普说，订单根本就没来。
Only about 5% of customer orders after that ad campaign came by phone. The rest were just done the old way. Someone filled out a paper form, wrote a check, put it in an envelope, stamped, it mailed it in the same slow process that they've been doing since the dawn of mail order retail. Yeah, the same slow, sort of high friction shopping that had always happened. Yeah, the cultural habit of kind of instant shopping, instant gratification, it just wasn't there. And as one ad industry writer put it at the time, the public is, quote, not used to the convenience as yet, end quote. But that would change as we get into the 1970s, thanks in part to another technology
在那次广告活动之后，只有大约 5% 的客户订单是通过电话下的。其余的依然是通过老方法完成的。有人填写纸质表格，写支票，放进信封，贴上邮票，寄出去——采用的还是自邮购零售诞生以来一直在用的那种缓慢的流程。对，就是那种一直以来都存在、缓慢且摩擦力很大的购物方式。对，那种即时购物、即时满足的文化习惯，当时根本就不存在。正如当时一位广告业作家所说，公众“目前还不习惯这种便利”。但随着我们进入 20 世纪 70 年代，这种情况将会改变，这在一定程度上要归功于另一项当时正在普及的技术。
that was gaining popularity at the time, the credit card. With only one credit card, the Bank Amera card, you can charge almost anything, almost anywhere. The Bank AmeriCard gives you instant credit from Boston to Honolulu, from London to Bangkok. The Bank of America card will soon be coming to Southern Ohio as another service. The credit card is kind of a requirement for this all to work seamlessly. Right. Like now you mention it. Like calling a 1-900 number only sort of reduced.
——信用卡。只需一张信用卡，美国银行卡（BankAmericard），你几乎可以在任何地方购买任何东西。美国银行卡为您提供从波斯顿到檀香山、从伦敦到曼谷的即时信贷。美国银行卡很快将作为另一项服务登陆俄亥俄州南部。要让这一切无缝运行，信用卡可以说是必不可少的条件。对。经你这么一说。就像拨打 1-900 电话只是在某种程度上减少了这种阻力，你知道的，仅仅是在链条的一个小环节上。信用卡确实让长途订购变得更有可能。对。我的意思是，在信用卡出现之前，还有其他方式可以通过电话付款。比如，你可以有一个商店记账账户。对。或者你可以使用一种叫做货到付款的东西，基本上就是当商品送达时向送货员付款。但信用卡让整个过程变得更加方便。它们真正释放了 800 电话用于购物的潜力。你总是想展现出最好的状态。但你最没时间做的事就是购物。
this friction, you know, in one small part of the chain. Like the credit card really makes the long-distance ordering more possible. Right. I mean, there were other ways to pay over the phone before credit cards. Like, you could have a store charge account. Yeah. Or you could use something called cash on delivery, where you basically pay the delivery person when the item arrives. But credit cards made this whole process just way more convenient. And they really unlocked the 800 numbers potential for shopping. You always want to look your best. But the last thing you have time to do is shop.
这就是为什么有了斯皮格尔（Spiegel）商品目录。它里面装满了你喜爱的各种造型。所以这是一则斯皮格尔的电视广告，它也是一家前身是邮购零售商的公司，以前曾销售过家具等商品。他们最终转型为女性工作服。这真是一次彻底的转型。是的，但斯皮格尔能够在 800 电话时代成功转型，将营业时间延长到营业时间之外，变成了 7×24 小时的零售模式。
That's why there's the Spiegel catalog. It's filled with all the looks you love. So this is a TV ad for Spiegel that was also a former mail order retailer that had previously sold things like furniture. And they eventually pivoted to women's workwear. That is quite a re-rent. Yeah, but Spiegel was able to transform during the 800-number era to extend past business hours into a 24-7 retail model.
你知道，它想要服务那些忙碌的职业父母，他们晚上把孩子哄睡着，然后不得不赶在睡觉前塞进购物时间。对斯皮格尔来说，这是一种非常 lucrative（赚钱）的模式。你可以在晚上比如九点、十点打个电话，对吧？你可以顺应那种在一天中的这些时候想要买东西的冲动，你知道的，
You know, it wanted to serve busy working parents who put the kids to bed at night and then had to cram in their shopping before they went to sleep. And this was a really lucrative model for Spiegel. You could make a telephone call at, say, 9, 10 o'clock at night, right? You could act on the impulse of wanting to buy something in these parts of the day when, you know,
在这些时候，买东西简直是不可想象的，对吧？你知道，营销人员希望人们顺应自己的冲动，你知道，当这种冲动强烈时，800 电话让这变得更有可能。没错。所以美国消费者现在终于能够纵情享受一天中随时随地购物的即时满足感了。是的，他们在做出可能在财务上具有毁灭性的决定时，不再受时间限制了。另一件真正让 800 电话在 20 世纪 80 年代腾飞的事情是 AT&T 的分拆。从今天起，全国性的贝尔电话系统解散为七家区域性公司。AT&T 的分拆让许多人感到困惑，并促使一个音乐组合录制了一首讽刺歌曲。
it just wouldn't have been conceivable to purchase something, right? You know, marketers want folks to, you know, act on their impulse, you know, when the impulse is strong and the 800 number makes that more possible. Right. So American consumers are now finally able to give into that instant gratification of shopping at any time of the day. Yes, they are not time limited in making potentially financially ruinous decisions. And another thing that happened that really made 800 numbers take off in the 1980s was the breakup of. AT&T. As of today, the nationwide bell telephone system dissolves into seven regional companies. The breakup of AT&T has left many people confused and prompted one musical group to record a satirical song.
如果你想要一个免费电话号码，它很可能是由 AT&T 颁发的。当时，这家公司是一家垄断企业，因此要获得这些号码相当昂贵。但在 80% 年代初的一场反垄断诉讼之后，AT&T 被迫分拆成几家其他公司以鼓励竞争。这之后，800 电话的价格开始下跌。突然之间，以前买不起免费专线的小企业，现在买得起了。想象一下拥有世界上最伟大的情歌。致电 1-800-6806 订购终极情歌精选集。要订购您的贝蒂妙厨培根酥，请致电 1-800-7。
If you wanted a toll-free number, it was probably being issued by AT&T. Now, the company was a monopoly, and so those numbers were pretty expensive to get. But after an antitrust lawsuit in the early 80s, AT&T was forced to break into several other companies to encourage competition. And after that happened, prices for 800 numbers started to fall. And suddenly small businesses that could not afford a toll-free line before, well, now they could. Imagine owning the world's greatest love songs. Call 1-800-6806 to order the Ultimate Love Songs Collection. To order your Betty Crocker-Bacon-fill, call 1-800-7.
265。花 19.95 美元即可购买 212 期令人着迷的《Zubbooks》杂志。致电 1-800-441-2-400。培根酥。我其实不知道什么是贝蒂妙厨培根酥，但人们开始用 1-800 电话购买它们。他们开始购买 Zub 杂志以及你能想到的几乎所有其他东西。没错。
265. Two hundred twelve fascinating issues of Zubbooks for 1995. Call 1-800-441-2-400. Bacon-Fill. I don't really know what a Betty Crocker Bacon-Fill is, but people started to buy them with 1-800 numbers. They started to buy Zub books and pretty much anything else you can think of. Right.
所以，一旦 800 电话变得更加普及，通过这些免费专线究竟完成了多少商业交易呢？相当多。到 20 世纪 90 年代中期，价值超过 1300 亿美元的商品和服务都是通过 800 电话售出的。这个金额几乎占了整个国家 GDP 的 2%。天哪。就像 2%？这几乎和军费开支一样多。
So once the 800 number becomes more widespread, how much commerce was actually done over these toll-free lines? Quite a bit. By the mid-1990s, more than $130 billion worth of goods and services. were sold via 800 numbers. And that amount was nearly 2% of the entire country's GDP. Oh, crap. Like 2%, that's as much like his military spending.
对，那是大量的冲动购物。不久之后，公司意识到 800 电话不仅适合销售商品。它们也是宣传企业自身的绝佳途径。当时掀起了一股购买最佳靓号（vanity numbers）用于营销目的的热潮。这就是我们说到现在我们许多人都能铭记于心的那些 1-800 电话的时刻。所以我们说的是像 1-800-LAWYERS 这样的电话号码。立刻致电 1-800-LAWYERS。咨询免费，建议免费，而且我们每周七天、每天 24 小时营业。我们跨年夜午夜照常营业。所以请致电 1-800-LAWYERS。我们随时恭候。
Yeah, that's a lot of impulse shopping. And pretty soon, companies realized that 800 numbers were not just good for selling stuff. They were also a really good way to publicize a business itself. There was this rush to buy the best vanity numbers for marketing purposes. And this is the point where we get to those 1-800 numbers that a lot of us, know by heart today. So we're talking about phone numbers like 1,800 lawyers. Call 1,800 lawyers right now. The call is free, the advice is free, and we stay open 24 hours, seven days a week. We're open New Year's Eve at midnight. So call 100 lawyers. We're there right now.
真喜欢通过拨打 1-800-LAWYERS 来庆祝跨年夜。当然，还有 1-800-FLOWERS。当你想要用鲜花表达最美好的祝愿时，给我们打电话，我们会安排好一切。1-800-FLOWERS。只需拨打 8。在那家公司被称为 1-800-FLOWERS 之前，它最初只是纽约的一家实体花店。但那个 800 电话为它提供了一个平台，能够接触到全国各地数百万新客户，基本上是一天中的任何时间。我觉得最初我把 800 前缀当成了一种区号，但它实际上和区号有点相反，对吧？因为区号代表一个特定的地点和一个特定的时区。但当你拨打 800 电话时，你完全不知道
Love to celebrate New Year's Eve with a call to 1,800 lawyers. And then there was, of course, also 1,800 flowers. When you want to send your best wishes with flowers, call us, and we'll make all arrangements. Eighthundred flowers. Just call on eight. Before that company was called one eight hundred flowers, it started as just a single brick and mortar florist in New York. But that 800 number gave it the platform to reach millions of new customers all over the country, basically any time of the day. I feel like originally I thought of the 800 prefix as a kind of area code, but it's actually kind of the opposite of an area code, right? Because an area code signifies a specific place and a specific time zone. But when you're calling an 800 number, you have no idea
接电话的人身在何处，或者对他们来说现在几点。你只知道他们随时准备为你提供帮助，而且这是免费的。是的，确实如此。800 前缀确实感觉像是脱离了时间和空间。但有趣的是，如果你在免费电话热潮的鼎盛时期拨打 800 电话，实际上很有可能接听电话的人就在一个特定的地方。那就是内布拉斯加州的奥马哈。好吧，展开说说。好的，我来解释一下。因此，800 电话对公司的实体足迹产生了巨大影响，因为免费通话使得将客户服务集中到一个地方的巨大呼叫中心成为可能，而不必在全美每个城市的本地分支机构都配备人员。
where the person picking up the phone is located or what time it is for them. You just know that they are available to help you and that it's free. Yeah, that's true. The 800 prefix does kind of feel like it's removed from time and space. But the funny thing is that if you were calling an 800 number during the peak of the toll-free boom, there's actually a pretty good chance that the person picking up the phone was based in one specific place. And that was Omaha, Nebraska. Okay, say more. Okay, I'll explain. So the 800 number had a huge impact on companies' physical footprints, because toll-free calling made it possible to centralize customer service into like one giant call center in one place rather than staffing all these local branch offices in every city across America.
奥马哈实际上成了许多这类呼叫中心最终落户的地方。那么，为什么奥马哈会被选中享有这一殊荣呢？其实，奥马哈拥有大量的电话容量。其接入电话的容量大约是同等规模城市预期容量的两倍。这是因为二战后，空军将奥马哈选为其战略空军司令部的枢纽。这意味着他们基本上是在说，好吧，奥马哈将成为那个能够在冷战核末日中幸存下来的地方。他们在 20 世纪 40 年代和 50 年代期间
and Omaha actually became the place where many of these call centers ended up. So why was Omaha chosen for this great honor? So Omaha actually had a lot of phone capacity. It had about twice the capacity for incoming calls that you'd expect for a city of its size. And that's because after World War II, the Air Force chose Omaha as the hub for its strategic air command. What that means is they basically said, okay, Omaha is going to be the place. that will survive a Cold War nuclear apocalypse. And they laid a lot of phone lines coming into Omaha
铺设了大量通往奥马哈的电话线。所以，奥马哈为 1-800 时代做好了充分的准备。随时准备接听电话。而且公司高管也有一种信念，即奥马哈人有一种神话般的、中性的美国口音。因此，当奥马哈的呼叫中心员工接起电话时，对大多数美国人来说会听起来很熟悉。显然，这里有很多东西需要剖析，但我们不会去……
over the course of the 1940s and 50s. So Omaha was primed and ready for the 1-800 era. Ready to answer the call. And corporate executives also kind of had this belief that people from Omaha had like a mythical, neutral American accent. So when call center workers in Omaha picked up the phone, they would feel familiar to most Americans. Obviously, a lot to unpack there, which we're not going to get...
是的，说真的。但是，你知道，我们可以继续。但奥马哈确实迅速成为这个新兴免费经济的核心地带。到了 20 世纪 80 年代下半叶，如果你拨打一个 800 电话，很有可能会听到这样的话。1-800-LIVE-AID。我是朱迪。有什么我可以帮您的吗？
Yeah, for real. But, you know, we can keep going. But Omaha does quickly become this epicenter of the new toll-free economy. And by the second half of the 1980s, if you dialed an 800 number, there was a pretty good chance you'd hear something like this. 1-800 live-aid. This is Jody. May I help you?
这位是朱迪·拉瓦洛。她是来自奥马哈的业余历史学家。她曾在 20 世纪 80 年代中期全盛时期的一家呼叫中心工作。她说，这些呼叫中心彻底改变了奥马哈的经济。整个城市到处都是大型呼叫中心，它们都在招人。被录用很容易。你知道，工作岗位比人还多。总体而言，超过 10,000 名奥马哈人开始在呼叫中心工作，基本上充当了美国资本主义的幕后支撑。朱迪告诉我，对于她人生那个阶段的人来说，这是一份相当不错的工作。
So this is Jody Lavallo. She's an amateur historian from Omaha. And she worked in one of these call centers back in their hate. of the mid-1980s. And she says they pretty much transformed the economy of Omaha. There was just big call centers all across the city, and they were all hiring. It was pretty easy to get hired. There was, you know, more jobs than there were people. So overall, more than 10,000 Omahaans started working in call centers, basically serving as the back end of American capitalism. And Jody told me it was a pretty good job for someone in her stage of life.
我最喜欢的班次是下午四点到午夜。我喜欢把白天空出来留给个人事务。里面有空调。我们都有小耳机。我记得我和刚从高中毕业的朋友们坐在一起，是我把他们招进来的。所以朱迪在一个摆满几十个隔间的大房间里工作，里面坐着一部分她的高中同学。她的呼叫中心代表一大堆不同的公司和机构接听电话。因此，每当有电话打进来时，她的电脑屏幕上就会弹出一个剧本，用来推销 5 美元的 Craftmatic 可调节床或人造钻戒。
My favorite shift was like four to midnight. I'd like to have to have my days free for personal endeavors. It was air conditioned. We all had the little headsets. And I remember sitting together with just people I had gone to high school with that I had recruited. So Jody was working in a big room with dozens of cubicles populated in part by her high school friends. And her call center answered calls on behalf of like a whole bunch of different companies and organizations. So whenever a call came in, a script would pop up on her computer screen to sell craftmatic adjustable beds or fake diamond rings for $5.
朱迪说，这些电话打进来的节奏有一种明显可察觉的规律。我们坐在那里一个电话也没有，突然它们全部亮了起来，然后全都是来自比如阿拉巴马州某个邮政编码的人，电视上刚刚闪过一条广告，比如：如果你想要你的 Diamond L 戒指就打电话。
And Jody said there was a real discernible kind of rhythm to how these calls came in. We would be sitting there not having any calls and all of a sudden they would all light up and it would be everybody from like Alabama in a certain zip code and something had flashed on the TV like, call if you get your diamond L ring.
然后那个邮政编码里的每个人都会同时打电话。接着我们大家就会同时变得忙碌，因为我们会觉得，哦，广告刚播完。有时候，电话多得让人应付不过来。这方面的一个好例子其实发生在朱迪入职之前，即 1977 年 8 月，也就是猫王埃尔维斯·普雷斯利去世后不久。各大公司开始在电视上狂轰滥炸地播放推销猫王纪念品
And then everybody like in that zip code would call at the same time. And then we would all get busy like at the same time because we like, oh, the commercial just went on. And there were times when the calls became overwhelming. A good example of this actually came before Jody's time back in August of 1977, just after the death of Elvis Presley. Companies started flooding the TV with commercials selling Elvis merchandise
和精选专辑的广告。20 首巨星金曲，两张大盘专辑，外加独家珍藏画册，只需 7.98 美元即可拥有。要订购这份对猫王的最后致敬，请拨打免费电话 1-800-22-9。有太多人拨打 800 电话来获取他们心中的猫王历史片段。它甚至导致系统瘫痪，奥马哈周围的区域电话线都中断了。这就是摇滚之王和 800 电话结合的力量。这真是无可匹敌。
and greatest hits albums. 20 giant hits, two big albums, plus the exclusive bonus picture book, yours for just 798. To order this final tribute to Elvis, call toll-free, 1-800-22-9. And so many people called the 800 number to get their piece of Elvis history. It actually crashed the system, and the regional phone lines around Omaha went down. It's the power of the king and the 1-800 number combined. This is unbeatable.
对，但她说她最喜欢接听的电话是为“拯救生命”（Live Aid）演唱会打来的。我不想暴露你的年龄，罗曼，但你一定记得 Live Aid，对吧？哦，对，当然。绝对记得。那是一件大事。对，所以对于 Gen Z 或更年轻的任何人来说，Live Aid 是一场巨大的电视转播音乐会，举办于 1985 年 7 月。这场音乐会是一场为支持埃塞俄比亚饥荒救援而筹款的活动。演出阵容简直强大得不真实。有皇后乐队、U2、大卫·鲍伊、Run DMC、保罗·麦卡特尼、蒂娜·特纳、齐柏林飞艇、
Yeah, but she said that her favorite calls to take were for live aid. I don't want to date you, Roman, but you must remember live aid, right? Oh, yeah, for sure. Absolutely. It was a big deal. Yeah, so just for anyone, Gen Z or younger, live aid was this huge, televised concert, and it happened in July of 1985. The concert was a fundraiser to support famine relief in Ethiopia. And the lineup was just unreal. There was Queen, U2, David Bowie, Run DMC, Paul McCartney, Tina Turner, Led Zeppelin,
麦当娜，有太多不可思议的艺术家了。回想起来，这可能是 800 电话的巅峰时期。因为 Live Aid 筹集资金的方式是让观众在音乐会期间拨打屏幕上的 800 电话。要进行捐款，请拨打 800-LIVE-AID。我们有数千名接线员随时准备接听您的电话。如果线路繁忙，请继续重试。号码是 800-L-I-V-E-A-I-D。
Madonna, just like so many incredible artists. And looking back, like, this may have been the high watermark for 800 numbers. Because the way that Live Aid raised money was by having viewers call the 800 numbers on screens during the concert. To make your pledge, dial 800 live aid. We've got thousands of operators ready to take your call. If the lines are busy, please keep trying. The number is 800 L-I-V-E-A-I-D.
我们保证公众捐出的每一美元都将送往非洲。立即致电。许多打电话的人都在直接与奥马哈的呼叫中心工作人员通话，比如朱迪。有时他们会打电话问，我们可以和辛迪·劳帕讲话吗？辛迪·劳帕在那儿吗？因为他们以为我们在那儿，你知道的，就在舞台上。他们给人的印象是，你与这项活动联系非常紧密。你就身临其境，但其实我们没有。
We guarantee every dollar given by the public will go to Africa. Call now. And many of those callers were speaking directly to call center workers in Omaha, like Jody. Sometimes they'd call and they go, can we speak to Cindy Lopper? Cindy Lopper there? Because they thought we were there, you know, at the stage. They have the impression that you are very connected to the event. You're very there, but we were not.
我们，你知道的，是在奥马哈的一个呼叫中心接听电话。你可以看看这些活动筹集了多少资金。其中很大一部分都是通过我们的手完成的。顺便提一下，辛迪·劳帕实际上并没有在 Live Aid 上表演。这是一个重要的事实核查。她因健康问题不得不退出了。但这次活动相当成功。它最终筹集了远超 1 亿美元的资金。
We were, you know, in a call center, answering phones in Omaha. And you can look at how much money was raised for those events. And good lion's share of it came through our hands. A quick note, Cindy Lopper did not actually perform at Live Aid. She was an important fact check. She had to drop out because of a health issue. But the event was pretty successful. It ended up raising well over $100 million.
奥马哈的呼叫中心让这一切成为了现实。你知道，这些呼叫中心是让整个 1-800 商业模式运转的发动机房。在许多方面，它们为我们今天生活的现代 7×24 小时零售经济绘制了蓝图。我的意思是，它奠定了蓝图，但我实际拨打 1-800 电话已经是很久以前的事了。是的，这可能是很多人都有的观察。对 800 电话的需求在 20 世纪 90 年代和 2000 年代初确实走下坡路了。原因之一是手机。你知道，INWATS 的初衷是让客户打长途电话更实惠。但是，今天你的手机套餐可能包含某种统一费率或无限量全国通话。所以现在基本上
and Omaha call centers made it happen. You know, these call centers were the engine rooms that made the entire 1-800 business model run. And in many ways, they created the blueprint for the modern 24-7 retail economy that we live in today. I mean, it created the blueprint, but it's been a while since I actually call that 1-800 number. Yeah, that's probably an observation a lot of people have had. The demand for 800 numbers did go downhill in the 1990s and early 2000s. And we one reason for that is because of cell phones. You know, the original intent for Inwats was to make long-distance calling more affordable for customers. But, you know, today your cell phone plan probably has some kind of flat rate or unlimited nationwide calling. And so now there's basically
没有财务上的激励让公司去申请一个 1-800 前缀供客户拨打。没错。因为现在，我给奥克兰的人打电话和给你在波士顿打电话，价格是一样的。而且只需按分钟计费。套餐就是这样运作的。对。而且，就像许多其他行业一样，整合和外包把一大批呼叫中心的工作岗位送到了海外。是的。
no financial incentive for a company to get a 1-800 prefix for their customers to call. Right. Because today, it's the same price for me to call someone in Oakland as to dial you in Boston. And it's just it's minutes. That's just how plants work. Right. And also, like with so many other industries, consolidation and outsourcing, sent a whole bunch of these call center jobs overseas. Yeah.
然后，当然还有互联网，因为随后亚马逊登场了。没错。互联网让 800 电话作为购物平台几乎过时了。而且直接联系企业的任务也转移到了数字渠道，比如在线聊天、电子邮件应用程序和网页表单。是的。
And then, of course, there's the internet, because then Amazon comes on board. Right. The internet made the 800 number pretty much obsolete as a shopping platform. And then the task of reaching a business directly, that got shifted to digital channels too, like live chat, email apps and web forms. Yeah.
我也觉得给客服打电话——也就是进行语音通话——已经不是我孩子们经常做的事了。实际在电话里和别人交谈让他们感到极度焦虑，他们会不惜一切代价避免这种情况。就像昨天，家里最大的孩子在打电话，这让我大开眼界。真的，我只见过他们用手机刷 TikTok 和玩电子游戏。是的，不过我应该说，奥马哈依然有一些呼叫中心。比如如果你拨打 1-800-THE-OMNI 在奥马哈酒店预订房间，你可能会和那里的某个人通话。所以如果你渴望听到这种中立的、所谓的美国中立口音，你可以
I also feel like calling, like making a voice call to customer service is just not something, you know, my kids do very often. It fills them with great anxiety to actually talk to someone on the phone and they try to avoid it at all costs. Like yesterday, the oldest kid in the house was talking on the phone and it blew my mind. Like, I've only seen them use their phones for TikTok and playing video games, really. Yeah, I should say, though, that there are still some call centers in Omaha. like if you called 1-800 the Omni to make a reservation at an Omni hotel, you might talk to someone they're in Omaha. So if you're like itching to hear the neutral, quote-unquote neutral American accent, you can
拨打奥马哈酒店的电话。对，而且一分钱也不花。所以，你知道，这些 800 电话可能没有过去那么受欢迎了，但许多企业仍然拥有它们，它们依然存在，这是因为外面有很多依赖它们的人。并不是每个人都有高速互联网，并不是每个人都有手机无限流量，或者很多人没有浏览聊天机器人的技术素养。所以对于老年人、农村社区、低收入人群来说，
dial the Omni Hotel. Yeah, and it won't cost you a dime. So, you know, these 800 numbers, they're less popular maybe than they used to be, but many businesses still have them, they're still around, and that's because there are a lot of folks out there who rely on them. Not everybody has high-speed internet, not everybody has unlimited data on their phones, or a lot of people don't have the tech literacy to navigate a chatbot. So for seniors, rural communities, people with low incomes,
1-800 电话是一种向他们需要联系的企业提供免费、民主的生命线的途径。1-800 电话仍然是免费获得真人在线服务、无需花一分钱的无摩擦通道。这位是斯蒂芬·米尼克。斯蒂芬在电信行业工作多年，现在在乔治敦大学教书。他说，除了可访问性因素之外，我们仍然使用 800 电话的另一个原因是它们更具合法性。
the 1-800 number is a way to offer free democratic lifelines to the companies that they need to be able to contact. That 1-800 number remains the friction-free portal to get a live person online for free without having to pay a dime. This is Stephen Minnick. Stephen worked in the telecom industry for years, and now he teaches at Georgetown. And he said, on top of that accessibility factor, another reason we do still use 1-800 numbers is that they're just more legitimate.
嗯，我认为，人们很容易把它们视为也许是 20 世纪 80 年代、90 年代的遗物。但实际上，1-800 电话已经从单纯联系公司的一种方式，演变成了一个真正关乎信任和可访问性的工具。所以先说第一点，信任。有研究表明，与特定区号相比，人们本质上更倾向于拨打 800 电话。
Well, I think, you know, it's easy to think of them as being relics of the, maybe the 1980s, the 1990s. But really, 1-800-numbers have evolved from just a way to kind of reach out to a company into a tool that really talks about trust and accessibility. So that first piece, trust. There's research showing that people just inherently prefer calling an 800 number compared to a specific area code.
当你想到消费者看到一个免费电话号码时，它向他们发出信号，表明这家企业是成熟的。我们现在有很多垃圾电话，冒充本地区号，所以一个公认的免费电话号码给人们提供了一种合法性的庇护。需要明确的是，确实有骗子使用 800 电话，但它们要少得多，而且更难逃脱惩罚，因为企业必须在电话公司注册这些号码。这里的讽刺之处在于，企业仍然使用这些 800 电话来标榜信任、可访问性以及与人类对话的能力，但如今你越来越
When you think about a consumer sees a toll-free number, it signals to them that the business is established. We have a lot of spam calls, spoofing local area codes now, and so a recognized toll-free number gives people a sort of a shield. of legitimacy. To be clear, there are scammers who use 800 numbers, but they are much less common and it's just harder to get away with since businesses need to register those numbers with the phone company. The irony here is that companies still use these 800 numbers to signal trust and accessibility and the ability to talk to a human, but these days you're increasingly
有可能拨打一个 800 电话却接通了一个聊天机器人。对，对，这确实是个问题。但我看到 800 电话时总是很高兴。就像如果我在一个网站上遇到问题，却没有可以联系的号码，我会感到极其沮丧和愤怒。所以这让我很高兴它们还在坚持。嗯，很高兴能和你这个真人而不是聊天机器人交谈。谢谢你给我们带来的故事，丹。谢谢邀请我。我觉得你应该真为节目设立一条 1-800 热线，比如 1-800-99PI-POD 之类的，然后，你知道，所有人都可以打电话进来，多棒啊。我的意思是，我觉得我们可能会从打电话进来的听众那里得到不少好故事的创意，但我们也会接到很多怪人的电话。那就会变成：你们为什么不多做一些关于字体的故事？
likely to dial an 800 number and reach a chatbot. Yeah, yeah, that is a problem. But I'm always happy when I see an 800 number. Like if I, if I have a problem on a website and there is no number to reach, I get extremely frustrated and mad. So that makes me happy that they're still hanging on. Well, it was nice to speak to you, a real life human and not a chat bot. Thanks for bringing us the story, Dan. Thanks for having me. I think you should actually set up a 1-800 line for the show, like 1-800-99PI pod or something, and then, you know, everyone can call in with so great I mean, I think we might get quite a few good story ideas from people calling in, but we would also get like a lot of cranks. It would just be just like, why don't you do more stories about fonts?
没错，然后你就要为所有这些买单了。完全正确。我的意思是，那简直是自找苦吃。丹，这真的很有趣。我很感激。是的，谢谢邀请我。当我们从广告休息回来后，我们将重新审视一个关于免费电话终极形态的故事。请不要走开。
Right, and then you'd be footing the bill for all that. Exactly. I mean, just like, that would be just pain for my own misery. Dan, this is really fun. I appreciate it. Yeah, thanks for having me. When we come back from the break, we revisit a story about the toll-free numbers ultimate form. Stay with us.
我们的朋友肖恩·科尔一直对律师广告印象深刻。我应该说，完全被律师广告搞糊涂了。我的意思是，我只是在想，灾难镜头的片段或者你穿着法官长袍的表弟真的是代表你业务的最好方式吗？但我开始研究它们。这些律师广告，尤其是那种给人一种“飞过 90 年代底层捞油水”感觉的广告。这是律师某某某。
Our friend Sean Cole has always been impressed by lawyer ads. I would say more totally confused by lawyer ads. I mean, I'm just like, really like is disaster footage or your cousin wearing a judge's robe the best way to represent your practice? But I started looking into them. These lawyer ads in particular are the sort of like fly by 90 bottom feedery seeming ones. This is attorney blah, blah. Brown and Gruppin. Phillipson Associates.
布朗和格鲁平。菲利普森联合事务所。洛厄尔到重锤斯坦利。我会为你争取到很多钱……这里有某某某的伤害。骨头断裂。烧伤瘫痪。受害者。受害者。打电话给我。
Lowell to Hammer Stanley. And I'll get you lots of money for your. There are blah, blah, blar injuries. Crooked bones. Burned paralysis. Victim. Victim. Call me.
打电话给我。现在就打电话给我。现在就打电话给我。459。C-A-S-H！然后我掉进了井里，进入了律师广告监管的拜占庭式疯狂地下仙境，它有不同的时代和派别。
Call me. Call me right now. Call me right now. 459. CASS! And I fell down the well into the Byzantine crazy subterranean wonderland of lawyer advertising regulation, which has eras to it and factions. and there's this seemingly endless civil war in Lawyer Nation about whether lawyers should advertise their services at all. But first, let's just enjoy and indulge ourselves in some of the more excessive,
在律师界，似乎有一场无休止的内战，争论律师到底应不应该为他们的服务做广告。但首先，让我们先欣赏并沉溺于一些更过分的，
nay, surreal examples of the genre. Maestro? Here we go. If you've been in an auto accident, here are a few important tips. Don't give a statement. So these are the kinds of commercials you see at 3 in the morning on basic cable when everything is going wrong in your life. You've got your sort of central casting lawyer in front of a bookshelf, for whom every syllable and hand gesture is a hurdle.
甚至可以说是超现实的该类型的例子。大师？我们开始吧。如果你遭遇了车祸，这里有几个重要的提示。不要发表声明。所以这些就是你在深夜有线电视上看到的广告，当时你生活中的一切都出了问题。你面前有一位像是从演员库里挑选出来的、站在书架前的律师，对他来说，每一个音节和手势都是一道难关。
We understand the serious effects that an auto accident can have on your life. But then you have your performers. Permanently injured, size matters. The bigger your check, the better. I'm Lowell, the hammer stand. I love Lowell, the Hammer Stanley. There are images of airborne cars engulfed in flames playing behind him right now. I don't stop hammering until the size of your check satisfies you.
我们了解车祸会对您的生活造成严重影响。但接着你看到了那些表演者。永久受伤，尺寸很重要。你的支票越大越好。我是重锤斯坦利，洛厄尔。我喜欢重锤斯坦利，洛厄尔。他身后正播放着空中汽车陷入火海的画面。在我对支票的尺寸满意之前，我绝不会停止重击。
Call me, and let's talk about size. Lowell, the Hammer, Stanley. There's actually more than one hammer in this tool bench. I'm Jim Abbott, the Texas Hammer. I avenge injustice for the injured, the mistreated, and they ignored. There's even more than one hammer named Jim. I'm Jim the Hammer. Hammer Shapiro.
打电话给我，让我们来谈谈尺寸。重锤斯坦利，洛厄尔。其实这个工具箱里不止一把锤子。我是德州重锤吉姆·阿伯特。我为受伤者、受虐待者和被忽视者复仇雪恨。甚至还有不止一个叫吉姆的锤子。我是锤子吉姆。锤子夏皮罗。
I swear to God I thought this one was a joke. I cannot rip out the hearts of those who hurt you. I cannot hand you their severed heads. But I can hunt them down and settle the score. I'll squeeze them for every dime I can. So those are the Crusaders. I mean, it's still all about money, but, you know, they have a Captain America protector quality about them.
我发誓我以为这个是个笑话。我无法挖出那些伤害你的人的心。我无法把他们被砍下的脑袋交给你。但我可以把他们揪出来，了结这笔账。我会榨干他们身上的每一分钱。所以这些就是十字军。我的意思是，这仍然全是为了钱，但你知道，他们有一种美国队长式的保护者特质。
And a few of these things, though, it's just pure, unfettered crassness. I was in pain, and I called Spencer and a social. and he changed my pain to rain. At which point money falls all over her body, usually only happens in the strip club. The pain to rain alchemical process is fundamental to lawyer television. Your injury is a commodity.
不过，其中有几部广告，简直是纯粹、毫无掩饰的粗俗。我当时很痛苦，我打了斯宾塞父子的电话，他把我的痛苦变成了降雨。在这一点上，钱落满了她的全身，通常这只发生在脱衣舞俱乐部里。从痛苦到降雨的炼金术过程是律师电视广告的基础。你的受伤就是一种商品。
And apparently, cashing in is a cinch. Call me. It's just that easy. Call me. It's just that easy. Call 1-877 C. And, you know, look, I grant you, these things are almost majestically terrible,
显然，兑现轻而易举。打电话给我。就是这么简单。打电话给我。就是这么简单。拨打 1-877-C-A-S-H。你知道，听着，我承认，这些东西几乎可以说是宏伟的糟糕，
right? This is Bob Garfield, co-host of the NPR, WNYC show on the media. For 25 years, he was the ad critic for Advertising Age magazine. There is no attempt
对吧？这位是鲍勃·加菲尔德，NPR 和 WNYC 节目《媒体观察》的联合主持人。25 年来，他一直是《广告时代》杂志的广告评论家。这里没有任何
for subtlety. It is the hard sell. There have been a few of these lawyers over the years who have tried to be funny. You know, a lot of personal injury lawyers
微妙的尝试。这就是硬推销。多年来，有少数这样的律师试图走搞笑路线。你知道，很多个人伤害律师
sometimes in order to cast themselves in their own ads. We'll do some sort of nominally comic scenario that they're star of. How can you tell when a lawyer is lying? When his lips are moving, that is funny and lawyer jokes are great. But let's get serious. Uh, but basically it's, you know, the keywords are
有时为了在自己的广告中出镜。会搞一些名义上具有喜剧色彩的场景，而他们自己就是主角。你怎么知道一个律师在撒谎？当他的嘴唇在动时，这很有趣，律师笑话也很棒。但让我们严肃点。呃，但基本上，你知道，关键词是
call now. Call the rely on group now. Because like, obviously the cynical view is like, hear her some sharp... Call the Goldwater Law Firm now. If you or a loved one has had a Depew hip replacement. Call the Goldwater Law firm right now. You know, I have a certain grudging respect. Having looked over and over and over for 25 years at extremely artful executions of fairly obscure creative ideas, I am so delighted to see somebody saying,
现在就打电话。现在就打电话给雷莱集团。因为很明显，愤世嫉俗的观点是：听听这些精明的……现在就打电话给戈德华特律师事务所。如果你或你的爱人做过德普髋关节置换手术。现在就打电话给戈德华特律师事务所。你知道，我有一种勉为其难的敬意。在连续 25 年一遍又一遍地看着对相当晦涩的创意想法进行极其巧妙的执行之后，我非常高兴地看到有人在说：
I got something to sell. I think you should buy it. Call now. It's honest. It's honest. Now, sometimes of dubious legality, because the ads themselves frequently skirt the legality of solicitation. Different jurisdictions have different rules.
我有东西要卖。我认为你应该买它。现在就打电话。这很诚实。这很诚实。现在，有时合法性存疑，因为广告本身经常游走在招揽客户的合法性边缘。不同的司法管辖区有不同的规则。
This is what I was talking about in the beginning. Rules regarding what you can and can't say in an ad, who can appear in your ad and what they're allowed to say about you. All of that is regulated to tighter or looser degrees by each individual state bar association and state Supreme Court because, as proven by history, lawyers will tout themselves exactly as, loudly as they're allowed to.
这就是我一开始谈到的。关于你在广告中能说和不能什么、谁可以出现在你的广告中以及他们被允许对你说什么，都有相关规则。所有这些都受到各个州律师协会和州最高法院不同程度的严格或宽松监管，因为正如历史所证明的那样，律师会毫不掩饰、尽可能大声地宣传自己。
See, back in the 19th century, you'd see ads for attorneys on the front page of newspapers, alongside ads for doctors and saddle and harness manufacturers. But in 1908, the American Bar Association put in new rules saying all instances of self-laudation, that's what they called it, self-lawdation, defy the traditions and lower the tone of our high calling and are intolerable. Business guards were okay. That ban lasted about 70 years. And then in 1976, the law clinic of Bates and Osteen
你看，早在 19 世纪，你就会在报纸头版看到律师广告，旁边还有医生以及马鞍和挽具制造商的广告。但在 1908 年，美国律师协会出台了新规则，规定所有自吹自擂的行为——他们就是这么叫的，自吹自擂——都违背了传统，拉低了我们崇高使命的基调，是不能容忍的。业务名片还可以。这项禁令持续了大约 70 年。然后在 1976 年，贝茨与奥斯汀律所
ran one little classified in the Arizona Republic saying, Do you need a lawyer? Legal services at very reasonable fees, divorce, adoption, bankruptcy, blah, blah, blah. And in short, the Arizona bar got mad and suspended the two lawyers. Bates and Osteen appealed all the way to the U.S. Supreme Court. And in the now infamous Bates v. State Bar of Arizona, the court ruled that lawyers have the same freedom of speech as everybody else. Gaville-Gavel, lawyers can advertise. Then all hell broke loose.
在《亚利桑那共和报》上登了一条小小的分类广告，上面写着：“你需要律师吗？提供收费非常合理的法律服务，离婚、收养、破产，等等等等。”简而言之，亚利桑那州律师协会非常生气，并暂停了这两名律师的执业资格。贝茨和奥斯汀一路将案件上诉到美国最高法院。在如今声名狼籍的“贝茨诉亚利桑那州律师协会案”中，最高法院裁定，律师和其他所有人一样享有言论自由。法槌一敲，律师可以做广告了。接着，混乱便一发不可收拾。
That pretty much opened up the floodgates. This is Elizabeth Tarbert, the Ethics Council for the Florida Bar. She runs the department that regulates lawyer advertising there. There was kind of a wild, wild west situation where lawyers were advertising any way they wanted because there weren't regulations. where there had been just flat out prohibitions. So Florida actually had a couple of different Blue Ribbon commissions, and they adopted the first set of rules,
这几乎彻底打开了闸门。这位是伊丽莎白·塔伯特，佛罗里达州律师协会的道德顾问。她负责管理该州的律师广告监管部门。当时那里的情况就像狂野的美国西部，律师们想怎么打广告就怎么打，因为根本没有什么规章制度，而在此之前，这些行为是完全被禁止的。因此，佛罗里达州实际上成立了几个不同的精英委员会，他们通过了第一套规则，
and because bar leadership was very concerned about what statements lawyers were making in their advertisements to try to get clients. Elizabeth Tarbert wasn't with the bar back then, so she doesn't know what those ads looked like. But an attorney I talked to named Steve Miller does. Look, when I first started practicing... He's a divorce lawyer with offices in Florida and Massachusetts. She sets. I worked for a woman in Florida doing personal injury work. And she was one of, I won't see
因为律师协会领导层非常担心律师在广告中为了拉拢客户会发表什么言论。伊丽莎白·塔伯特当年并不在律师协会工作，所以她不知道当时的广告是什么样子的。但我采访过的一位名叫史蒂夫·米尔斯的律师知道。“听着，当我刚开始实习的时候……”他是一名离婚律师，在佛罗里达州和马萨诸塞州都设有办公室。“我在佛罗里达州为一名女性工作，从事人身伤害诉讼。她是那种——我不会说……”
she was one of the first on TV, but she did a lot of TV advertising. And her ad went something like this. You hear a car crash. You would hear a car crash, see, hear the sirens, and then they threw a doll, a baby doll into the picture, which on the, on the, you. On the, you know, on the, you. On the, never forget it. I won't say her name. But it was just the worst thing that I ever seen. And so I'm sure that had something to do with the bar coming in and saying, look, you can't, you can't do music, you can't do dramatizations, you can't have your clients come on. You can't do that stuff. It actually goes way beyond that. Florida has some of the strictest guidelines in the country for these ads. For instance, testimonials, if a lawyer writes the testimonial, him or herself, that would be
她不是最早出现在电视上的人之一，但她做了很多电视广告。她的广告大概是这样的。你听到车祸的声音。你会听到车祸的声音，听到警笛声，然后他们在画面中扔进了一个洋娃娃，一个婴儿娃娃，在……在……你知道的……在……永远不会忘记。我不会说出她的名字。但这绝对是我见过最糟糕的事情。所以，我确信这与律师协会介入并表示“听着，你不能这样做，你不能用音乐，你不能搞情景再现，你不能让你的客户出镜，你不能做这些事情”有很大关系。实际上，它的范围远不止于此。佛罗里达州拥有全国针对这些广告的最严格的准则。例如，证言，如果由律师自己撰写证言，那将是
misleading, that's not the person's actual experience. If it's not the person's actual experience with a lawyer, they're not qualified to judge the lawyer, then those things would be misleading. Now, think of how many lawyer commercials you've seen that use testimonials. The insurance company kept asking me to hurry up and sign a release. I was thinking, what's the rush? Of course they wanted Jason to sign quickly. Of course some of them are written by the attorneys, or their advertising consultants. Oftentimes, the actual client doesn't even appear in the ads. Jason Smith. He is not Jason Smith. He's an actor performing a testimonial, which is also prohibited in Florida.
具有误导性的，那并不是当事人的真实经历。如果这不是当事人与律师的真实交往体验，他们就没有资格评价律师，那么这些内容就会具有误导性。现在，想想你见过多少使用当事人证言的律师广告？“保险公司一直催促我赶快签署谅解书。我在想，急什么？”当然，他们希望杰森赶快签字。当然，其中一些是律师或他们的广告顾问写的。通常情况下，真正的客户甚至都不会出现在广告中。“杰森·史密斯。”他根本不是杰森·史密斯。他是一个在表演证言的演员，这也是佛罗里达州所禁止的。
Nor are you allowed in Florida to have actors playing authority figures, like cops and judges, saying how great the lawyer is. Nor are you allowed to have actual cops and judges saying how great the lawyer is. People inherently respond to authority figures, whether they're real or not. So we prohibit their use in advertisements. Does Robert Vaughn fall under that category? I wouldn't consider Robert Vaughn an authority figure. he's an actor, but he would fall within the prohibition in the same role about using the voice or image of a celebrity. Again, kind of pervasive in other states. Tell the insurance companies, you mean business. Tell them you've hired Jacobian Myers. They go after your rights, peace by piece by peace until justice has been served.
在佛罗里达州，你也不允许让演员扮演权威人物（如警察和法官），来说明这位律师有多么优秀。同样，你也不允许让真正的警察和法官来说明这位律师有多么优秀。人们对权威人物有着天生的回应倾向，不管他们是真是假。因此我们在广告中禁止使用他们。罗伯特·沃恩属于这一范畴吗？我不会认为罗伯特·沃恩是权威人物，他是一位演员，但他将受到关于不得使用名人声音或形象的相同禁令的限制。同样，这种现象在其他州也相当普遍。“告诉保险公司，你是认真的。告诉他们你雇了雅各布和迈尔斯。他们会一点一点地剥夺你的权利，直到正义得以伸张。”
They'll be in court. Call Jacobian Myers. Elizabeth Tarbert says the rules are meant to protect the public, that people should pick a lawyer based on what she calls objective selection. criteria rather than fancy pants promises and sound effects. If you break the rules, the penalties are not really that dramatic. The worst that might happen is that you'll get what's known as a public reprimand. The bar sends out a press release, so your reputation is kind of marred, but it's not like you're going to be disbarred.
“他们会奉陪到底。打电话给雅各布和迈尔斯。”伊丽莎白·塔伯特说，这些规则旨在保护公众，人们应该根据她所说的客观选择标准来挑选律师，而不是靠花哨的承诺和音效。如果你违反了规则，惩罚其实并没有那么戏剧化。最糟糕的结果可能也就是受到所谓的公开谴责。律师协会会发布一份新闻稿，所以你的名誉会有点受损，但这并不是说你会被吊销律师执照。
So that's Florida. There are a few other states that are strict. Iowa and Texas, weirdly, given that it's home to one of the hammers. Insurance companies rarely play fair and handover a few. They must be hammered and hammered before they see the light. I'm Jim Aver. Massachusetts and Connecticut are still pretty wild westy. And if you're a national firm operating in a bunch of jurisdictions, you have to comply with multiple sets of rules.
这就是佛罗里达州的情况。还有其他几个州也很严格。奇怪的是，得克萨斯州和艾奥瓦州也很严格，毕竟得州是其中一个“铁锤”的大本营。“保险公司很少讲公平，轻易交出赔偿金。必须狠狠地砸，狠狠地砸，他们才会幡然醒悟。我是吉姆·艾弗尔。”马萨诸塞州和康涅狄格州仍然相当具有西部荒野风格。如果你是一家在多个司法管辖区运营的全国性律师事务所，你就必须遵守多套不同的规则。
That's what Lucian Pera has to deal with. He's a lawyer with Adams and Reese in Memphis. And among other things, he advises nationwide firms on their advertising. And sometimes he'll be looking over the disclaimer rules, for example, and he'll be like, Okay. State A says you got to say this. But state B, if I say what state A says, state B is going to say, well, I can't say exactly that. So I got to weave it together somehow. It is a morass. It does what it's, I think, in my opinion, intended to do, which is it deters lawyer advertising to some significant extent. Now, Lucian state, Tennessee, is pretty loose. In fact, it's been widely reported of late as the state where you'll see lawyer ads featuring space aliens, giant robots, and both dogs and cars that, can talk. Guys, come here.
这就是卢西安·佩拉必须应付的情况。他是孟菲斯亚当斯兼里丝律师事务所的一名律师。除其他工作外，他还为全国性的律师事务所提供广告方面的咨询。有时，他会查看免责声明的规则，例如，他会想：“好吧，A州说你必须这样说。但B州规定，如果我说了A州要求的话，B州就会说，嗯，我不能完全那样说。所以我必须某种程度上把它们编织在一起。”这是一个泥潭。我认为，它达到了其设计初衷，在很大程度上阻碍了律师广告。现在，卢西安所在的州——田纳西州，相当宽松。事实上，最近有广泛报道称，在该州你会看到以太空外星人、巨型机器人以及会说话的狗和汽车为特色的律师广告。“伙计们，过来。”
Huh? All the cars in town are talking about you. Talking cars. They say you're the go-to guys for car wrecks. And even now, more than 35 years later, Lucian says there's a cohort of lawyers who will see an ad like that and say, look what Bates versus State Bar of Arizona hath rot. There are many lawyers today, many lawyers today who feel that much that is wrong with the profession today, if not all that is wrong with the profession today,
“啊？”“全城的车都在谈论你们。”“会说话的车。”“它们说你们是处理车祸的首选。”即使在今天，也就是35年多以后，卢西安说，依然有一群律师看到这样的广告会说：“看看贝茨诉亚利桑那州律师协会案带来了什么。”今天有许多律师，今天的许多律师认为，当今法律界存在的许多问题，如果说不是全部问题的话，
dates from dates, that lawyer advertising turned us from a profession into a business. And they just think it's undignified for lawyers to be on television pitching their services generally, much less talking to dogs or aliens. They just think that demeans the profession. And you don't have to look too far down the road in Tennessee to find one of those lawyers, namely Matt Hardin, a personal injury attorney in Nashville, with his own practice. I'm sorry.
都可以追溯到那个时候，正是律师广告把我们这个职业变成了一门生意。他们只是觉得律师上电视推销自己的服务很不体面，更不用说跟狗或外星人对话了。他们只是认为这有辱律师职业的尊严。在田纳西州，你不难找到这样的一位律师，也就是纳什维尔的人身伤害律师马特·哈丁，他拥有自己的事务所。“对不起。”
I've got a big bunch on this. The first half of it's about the history of advertising. Last year, he and the Tennessee Association for Justice, which is a group of plaintiff's lawyers, filed two petitions to the state Supreme Court asking them to change the advertising rules in Tennessee so that they essentially looked more like the ones in Florida. There was a public comment period, some First Amendment advocates got involved, and ultimately, the court said no. Matt is determined to keep trying. And I asked him. And so do you think Bates was the sort of the beginning
“我对此有很多看法。”其中前半部分是关于广告的历史。去年，他和代表原告律师群体的田纳西州正义协会向州最高法院提交了两份请愿书，要求他们修改田纳西州的广告规则，使其基本上看起来更像佛罗里达州的规则。当时有一个公众评议期，一些第一修正案倡导者也参与其中，但最终法院拒绝了。马特决心继续尝试。我问他：“那么，你认为贝茨案是某种类似大爆炸的、导致律师地位堕落的毁灭之始吗？”“我是这么认为的。我的意思是，如果你看看我们的历史，在20世纪50年代和60年代，人们把律师视为正义的倡导者。你知道，甚至可以追溯到像《杀死一只知更鸟》这样的作品。但是，那些我称之为公众对律师呈正面看法的黄金时代，似乎已经一去不复返了。不幸的是，大多数人看到的都是这种令人反感的广告，他们根据这些广告来对律师形成看法。不过我最大的担忧是，这会如何影响陪审团候选人库，让人觉得你只是为了捞钱。也就是说，如果人们开始认为原告和他们的律师只是为了
of the end, like the Big Bang that created the downfall of the sort of stature of lawyers? I do. I mean, if you look in the, you know, in our history in the 50s and 60s, you had lawyers being seen as a proponents of justice. You know, you have things as far back as like to kill a mockingbird. But those, what I would call the halcyon days of positive public perception of attorneys seem to be long gone. What most people see, unfortunately, is this unsavory advertising, and they base their opinions on lawyers on that advertising. But my, you know, my biggest concern about this is how it affects the jury pool and makes people think that you're just out for easy money. That is, if people start thinking plaintiffs and their attorneys are just out for
捞钱，他们可能会对整个司法程序产生愤世嫉俗的心态。而愤世嫉俗的人就会变成愤世嫉俗的陪审员，到时候谁也无法得到公正的审判了。”这就是其中的逻辑。顺便说一句，马特并不是全面反对打广告。“我自己也做广告。”“虽然不是在电视上。”“我在电影院里做广告。”“你在电影院里做广告？”“是的。”
easy money, they might get cynical about the process. And cynical people become cynical jurors, and no one gets a fair trial anymore. That's the calculus. And by the way, Matt's not opposed to advertising writ large. I advertise myself. Though not on TV. I advertise in movie theaters. You advertise in movie theaters? I do.
“还有在线上。”他的广告听起来是这样的：“发生事故后该怎么办？致电马特·哈丁律师事务所。您经验丰富的人身伤害律师事务所。”所以，你知道的，基调非常不同。视觉效果也是如此。这则广告中只有法槌、爱奥尼克柱以及马特的形象。
And online. His ads sound like this. What to do after an accident? Call Matt Hardin Law. Your experienced personal injury law firm. So, you know, very different tone. And visually, too. They're just images of gavels and ionic columns and Matt in this ad.
这让人不禁怀疑，他对那些狗狗和机器人商业广告的反感，背后是不是还有更深层的原因？“是不是仅仅因为你觉得这些广告不够档次？”“不，我觉得这不应该由我或其他人来评判一个广告是否有档次。”“但你确实觉得它们不够档次？”“我对这一点没有特别的意见。我的意思是，那并不是我真正想做的事。”“真的吗？因为我觉得我们所有人对此都有各自的看法。”
Which makes you wonder if maybe there's not something more basic about his objections to the dog and robot commercials. Is it just that you think the ads aren't classy? No, I don't think it's up to me or anyone else to make a judgment over what the class of an ad is. But do you think they're not classy? I don't have an opinion on that one way or another. I mean, that's not really what I'm trying to do. Really? Because I think all of us have an opinion on that one way or the other.
“我相信有些人确实会被那种类型的广告所疏远，但我认为如果它不管用的话，他们就不会这么做了。”“你觉得它管用吗？”“当然，确实管用。”“它们确实管用，是的。对于那些吸引到的群体来说，它们确实管用。”“我是‘铁锤’洛厄尔·斯坦利。我就是铁锤。”
I believe some people are actually turned off by that type of advertising, but I don't think they would do it if it didn't work. You think it works? Absolutely, it does. They do work, yes. They do work for those that they appeal to. This is Lowell the Hammer Stanley. I am the Hammer.
“这就像在看YouTube。就是这样。”我好像没提过。 “铁锤”洛厄尔·斯坦利在弗吉尼亚州诺福克执业。他当律师已经超过30年了。说实话，当我要问他他的广告到底是是怎么回事时，我还有点紧张。但我还没来得及问，他就自己回答了。“这些广告并不高级。”
It's just like watching YouTube. That's what it is. I don't think I mentioned. Lowell the Hammer Stanley practices in Norfolk, Virginia. He's been a lawyer for more than 30 years. And truthfully, I was a little nervous about asking him what the hell was up with his ads. But he answered the question before I even got to it. The ads are not sophisticated.
“我很高兴你知道这一点。如果我看到自己的广告，就我个人而言，我绝不会打电话找自己。”“真的吗？”“是的，这些广告对我没有什么吸引力。它们过于夸张了，有些人甚至可能认为它们毫无品味。但它们并不是为了吸引像我这样听国家公共广播电台（NPR）和看公共电视台（PBS）的人。它们的设计是为了吸引那些看像杰瑞·斯普林格秀之类节目的人，他们都是很好、很善良、很正派的人，但他们习惯了商业广告，他们想要的是一个
I'm glad that you know that. If I saw my ad, me personally, I would never call me. Really? Yes, the ads do not appeal to me. They are over the top, and some might even consider them tasteless. But they are not designed to appeal to people like me who listen to NPR and watch PBS. they're they are designed to appeal to people who watch shows like Jerry Springer or things like that who are good and fine and decent people but they are used to commercials and they bottle
会为他们战斗的人，而这正是这些广告旨在吸引的对象。”听起来有点像阶级区分。“嗯，这可能被认为是一种阶级区分。如果你是一个受过教育的人，是个博士或银行家，你不需要从广告中去找律师。你有朋友。你认识某人。你有家族律师。你可以去找他们。而这个广告是为辛勤工作的蓝领阶层、公交车司机、少儿棒球联盟教练准备的，是为那些受伤了却不知该向谁求助、没有律师、并且害怕律师却又希望有人能为他们战斗的人准备的。这正是它们旨在吸引的对象。”如果这是真的，佛罗里达州几乎肯定也有会被这些广告吸引的人。
is going to fight for them and that's what those ads are designed to appeal to. It sounds a little like a class distinction. Well, it may be considered a class distinction. If you are an educated person who's a Ph.D. or a banker or you don't need to get your lawyer from an ad. You have friends. You know somebody. You have a family lawyer. You go to them. This is designed for hardworking, blue collar, a bus driver, the little league coach, somebody who's hurt and doesn't know where to turn, doesn't have a lawyer. And it's afraid of lawyers and what somebody's going to fight for them. That's what they're designed to appeal to. And if that's true, there are almost certainly people in Florida whom those ads would appeal to.
所以最后，我问佛罗里达州律师协会的伊丽莎白·塔伯特：“如果我管自己叫‘铁锤’，在尖叫，身后还燃起熊熊烈火，这在那里行得通吗？”“我认为其中有些方面是无法客观验证的，而这是我们规则所要求的。”“也就是你去‘砸’他们。”“这是一个主观术语。”“没错。我无法证明我是在‘砸’人。”“注意，事故受害者、受害者、受害者！如果某人、某个地方欠你一大笔、一大笔钱，花钱请一个重量级人物，一个重量级人物是划算的。我是‘铁锤’洛厄尔·斯坦利，459。我是伤害案的复仇者。”
And so finally, I asked Elizabeth Tarbert at the Florida Bar, if I called myself the hammer and screamed and had flaming blazing behind me, would that be okay there? I think there are aspects of that that are not objectively verifiable, which is required under our rules. That you hammer them. That's a subjective term. Right. I can't prove that I hammer. Attention accident and victim, victim, victim. If someone, somewhere owes you big, big money, it pays to hire a heavyweight, a heavyweight. I'm Lowell, the Hammer Stanley, 459. I'm the Avenger for the Injury.
这个故事是“铁锤”肖恩·科尔在2014年制作的，它的一个版本最初在播客节目《法律的生活》中播出，并由茱莉亚·巴顿剪辑。本周的《不可思议》由丹尼尔·阿克曼报道，维维安·莱伊剪辑，马丁·冈萨雷斯混音，音乐由斯旺·里亚尔创作。事实核查由索娜·阿瓦基安负责。凯茜·2是我们的执行制片人。柯克·科尔斯特德是数字总监。德兰尼·霍尔是我们的高级编辑。团队其他成员包括克里斯·巴鲁贝伊、杰森·德莱昂、
That story was produced back in 2014 by Sean the Hammer Cole, a version of it originally aired on the podcast, Life of the Law, and was edited by Julia Barton. 99% Invisible was reported this week by Daniel Ackerman and edited by Vivian Lay, mixed by Martine Gonzalez, music by Swan Rial. Fact-checking by Sona Avakian. Kathy 2 is our executive producer. Kirk Colstead is the digital director. Delaney Hall is our senior editor. The rest of the team includes Chris Barubei, Jason DeLeon,
埃mett·菲茨杰拉德、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、瓦沙马德·唐、乔·罗森伯格、凯利·普赖姆、雅各布·麦地纳·格里森、塔林和雷恩·斯特德利，以及我，罗曼·马尔斯。《不可思议》的标志是由斯特凡·劳伦斯设计的。我们是天狼星XM播客家族的一部分，现在总部位于向北六个街区的潘多拉大楼内，位于美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市住宅区。你可以在所有常规社交媒体网站以及我们自己的Discord服务器上找到我们。在99PI.org上有通往该服务器以及99PI每一期往期节目的链接。“铁锤斯坦利，‘铁锤’洛厄尔·斯坦利，炸掉‘铁锤’斯坦利，四，五，九。”本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。
Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Washamad Don, Joe Rosenberg, Kelly Prime, Jacob Medina Gleason, Tallinn and Rain Stradley, and Me, Roman Mars. The 99% of us logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the Sirius X-N podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north, in the Pandora building. In beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find us on all the usual social media sites as well as our own Discord server. There's a link to that, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. Emperor Stanley, loo the hamper Stanley, blow up the hammer Stanley, four, five, nine. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Emmett Fitzgerald、Christopher Johnson、Washamad Don、Joe Rosenberg、Kelly Prime、Jacob Medina Gleason、Tallinn 和 Rain Stradley，以及我——Roman Mars。“我们这 99%”的标志是由 Stefan Lawrence 设计的。我们是 Sirius X-N 播客家族的一员，现在总部设在北边六个街区外的潘多拉大厦，位于美丽繁华的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市。你可以在所有常用的社交媒体网站以及我们自己的 Discord 服务器上找到我们。在 99PI.org 上有通往该服务器以及 99PI 每一期往期节目的链接。Emperor Stanley，loo the hamper Stanley，blow up the hammer Stanley，four，five，nine。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。